so what I'm going to show you is three
characteristics of simple harmonic
motion the first time most important one
you already know and that's its most
important because it's the one you use
to prove so if someone says or a
question says show that such and such is
moving in simple harmonic motion okay
this first characteristic that's the one
you're going to show much like you know
if you had to show that a functions an
even function okay what you have to
prove is this okay like that's the
result once you've got vanishing
therefore it's an even function okay so
I'm going to show you that first one you
should already know but then I'm going
to look at the other two I'm going to
show you how they work
not because you can quote them as actual
results but because you get asked to
prove them so often I might as well show
you how it works so number one and I
said you already know this it's the
differential equation for acceleration
hopefully if I say this enough times
it'll get um have it into your head my
sister's a dentist and she says if you
want people to do things like Foss or
brush waving their song like that you
have to say it three times and then they
actually remember it first and second
times it just totally go so the
differential equation for acceleration I
think I've said it like ten times now
but anyway what is the differential
equation for acceleration this is
acceleration for simple harmonic motion
what's it equal to remember success okay
so all this means is the further you get
away from the origin from your centre of
motion from your equilibrium position
the further away you get the more you
get pushed in the opposite direction
okay that's what that line this is about
okay so if you ever get asked to prove
that something simple for motivation
this is where you have to get you okay
but this leads to a couple of other
characteristics okay so firstly um what
kinds of functions obey this kind of
property I'll show this kind of
characteristic and the kind of
properties are sorry the kind of
functions are wave functions so anything
which using simple harmonic motion
should move according to a wave function
now do you render this back when we do
exhilarate angles okay the basic clients
of wave functions are x equals now I'm
going to give the standard form here a
sine M T plus alpha or so just your
regular old sine function or a cos
function now let's have a look at both
of these for a second you'll often get
us to describe the simple harmonic wave
particle okay just like you've been
asked to describe the motion of a
particle it slows down it stops that
kind of thing so what kinds of
characteristics do we know about these
all the same characteristics you
remember from like year 10 and graphing
trig functions okay so for instance
you're going to the airport to is a
okay so that's going to be a constant
you're going to need to know the period
how long does it take for this object to
go through one cycle or simple
confirmation and if you've got an N here
right this is a bit abstract so let's
just do a concrete example first sign X
right or sign so I remove T's right
think in radians what's the period of
sine T just regular all time 2pi radians
right so if I adjust it just a little
and make that two - how does that change
the period it in halves it great so in
other words because it's hootie I get
two full cycles within that original 2pi
right so two cycles into pi it was back
so therefore if I've got n at the front
once my period going to be the
relationship between period and this
coefficient is division right so here it
was 2pi on two so therefore here it will
be 2 pi on em so they'll ask you for
permission okay this guy hanging off
here is just the phase right but
importantly for the sine function right
it's going to tell you where you begin
so you might not actually start at the
origin you're going to start at an
offset now remember I told you we had
this idea of wave functions we
introduced the end of the name and when
we're doing auxiliary angle right to the
angle now when you look at these two
equations they're kind of already in
auxilary angle form
there's the exhibiter angle that effect
right but what did the equations come
from before before they cram it into one
sine function or one cosine function
what did they start off at
we actually have to do all of this work
we said things like sine X plus cos x
right is going to be root 2 sine and
then you've got whatever you want here
plus or minus alpha right whatever was
final six four and three or something
like that so therefore this is what
you're used to seeing right but one wave
function is the same as two wave
functions all three or four or five
right so you might not get one nice neat
one you might get two separate ones like
this just be careful with my letters
here yeah okay so I'm calling a B and C
because they have to be different
coefficients to this original egg right
and if I have two functions here so long
as they have the same period all right
I'm going to end up with another one of
these wave functions okay so any of
these they all exhibit some admission
all right so